well our one shot retaliation in the
name of the pain of every guy who took a
date to see a movie last winter or last
summer is finally here sorta Vampires
Suck Vampires Suck is exactly what you
think it's gonna be it's a spoof of
Twilight and New Moon crunched into one
movie no it was inevitable that a movie
like this would happen because the
Twilight movies because I will not call
it the Twilight Saga it's way too epic
are the opposing force to good cinema so
for you lucky souls out there who have
actually sat through the work of the
makers of this movie and I'm talking
about classic cinema like meet the
Spartans in disaster movie you haven't
fortunately been here before so you
understand the pain now Vampires Suck
had a couple of funny my I'd call them
chuckle moments but those rare moments
in this movie happened when the joke was
just one line that poked fun at the
ludicrous II that is the Twilight Saga
movies but instead 99% of the jokes in
this movie consist of someone getting
hit over the head with something or
running into something or getting hit by
something over and over and over and
over again it's just overused a note to
the creators of these shitty spoof
movies when a joke forces the audience
to use their brain in order to get the
joke it actually makes it funnier I mean
honestly it's not that these jokes got
old after the first two times they
happen is that they got old in 1982 I
feel like I'm ripping out the hearts of
my subscribers that want me to like this
movie because it bashes Twilight but
this movie had the comedic appeal of an
al-qaeda hostage video now not just
saying that this movie just genuinely
was not funny I mean it's just
counterproductive it is not insulting to
a franchise to make a movie spoofing
that franchise that's actually worse
than the franchise you're spoofing
that's right worse I mean the Twilight
movies are [ __ ] but I could stand
dr. cactus fingers giving me a physical
for 90 minutes over spending another 90
minutes sitting through this piece of
[ __ ] and when the end credits started
rolling here's how pathetic I got I
actually stayed for a couple minutes in
the credits just had a blind faith
because I was just hoping that something
funny might happen now and it was just
blind faith too because nothing I saw in
the previous 90 minutes even alluded to
the possibility that that might happen
now the funny thing is the actors in
this movie are actually better than the
actors in Twilight I'll say that but I
have this stomach-turning feeling that
Vampires Suck is gonna make more than
Scott Pilgrim this weekend the [ __ ]
horror so if you're a subscriber of mine
I imagine you like to laugh I mean who
doesn't but if it takes a little bit of
brain power to make you laugh just skip
this
[ __ ] I don't I don't know what to say
it's a pg-13 movie that's made for
six-year-olds best I can say it makes no
sense but that's it and there's the
first movie receiving my new awards
vampires sucks sucks bites and blows and
is awarded the dog [ __ ] award
congratulations horribly shitty movie
you're a pioneer it looks like we are
wrapping up the summer movie season
nicely but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more than click
right here to see more but don't watch
vampires suck
[Music]